to have uh alessio figale broadcasting
from eth is that right
yeah well from home now but uh yes
eph on the background
okay and alessia will tell us about a
singular set for the stefan problem
yeah so thank you very much craig and
thanks organizers for allowing me to
speak here um
so what i would present today is some
regulate of the free boundary the stefan
problem
so let me jump in
see now you're already a bit familiar
but let me just say it again
so the seventh problem
is actually was actually started first
originally by the main club iran before
stefano at the beginning of
1830s
and it's about describing temperature
distribution in a medium which undergoes
a phase transition let's say in my case
will be ice melting to water so not
freezing but melting
so stefan formulated many
problems so under the name of stefan
problems you have a lot of them
and
the one i will focus on is what's called
the one phase stefan problem so let me
explain to you
the setting is the following so
i have my domain which is like my
container where the ice and water live
so in this picture you see a cylinder
let's say
my unknown is the temperature here theta
this is the temperature
of the water
and i make a
very strong assumption
by asking tita to be zero in the ice so
it's one it's a one phase problem
because i'm i'm telling you that the ice
leaves at zero temperature so no no
negative temperature is allowed in this
model
and instead of course water is the
region where data is positive then
inside the water you have just classical
integration dtt equal laplacian theta so
the most natural evolution for the data
question
for the propagation
and but finally and this is the seventh
condition you need a condition that
tells you if you take a point here at
the interface
right so here this free boundary point
uh you have to tell you have to
prescribe how the free boundary evolves
depending on the temperature of the
water
and
the rule the stefan law here
is given by an od
so it tells me that the velocity so the
ice here is the current region so the
velocity here the free boundary
is going to be the negative gradient of
the temperature of the water at that
point so it's a node e for each particle
on the free boundary
so this is what i said is the one phase
problem
if you are in two phase
then this means that theta is less than
zero in the ice
and then you will have also an it
equation in the eyes so dp theta would
be laplacian theta
where theta is less than zero so you
will have a heat equation in the water
where it is positive at each equation in
the eyes
and then you will have a transmission
condition at the interface theta equals
zero which will involve both the
temperature of the water and temperature
of the ice in my case i have only one
temperature the one of the water so i
have a simpler room
now if you look it like this
you you wonder how the evolution goes
and just explain this
gratita
let me just show you a picture so this
is the ice
temperature zero this is the water
positive temperature you compute
at the interface the temp gradient of
the temperature in the positive region
and then you just take the opposite of
it and this is the speed
so you see in this picture here
that all the gradient is pointing
naturally inside therefore the ice is
shrinking so there is a direction of
time this is all this is a melting
process
now if you look in this way
um
probably you see no similarities with
inventors because
she had rather it equation with some
right hand side which was kind of
singular
uh here there is just a nice
interquestion
but there is another frame boundary
so
to connect them you need to you to do
what's called the bio dual
transformation which is a transformation
which is specific to the fact that we
are in the one phase setting
where
you define u to be the primitive of
theta so u is the integral from zero t
of theta
so dpu is theta itself
so you see that with this transformation
uh so this transformation is due to uh
biochem duo rough independently in two
slightly different settings and these
are in the 1970s
i think 1972 is the current year
uh so u is a non-negative function
because it's the
primitive of a non-negative function and
dtu is theta which is non-negative
assumption therefore u is
and then if you look at the pdf view
here it comes dpu minus laplacian u is
minus the characteristic of view
positive
which resembles much more
what
we saw in the other uh talk you can then
if you take the time derivative of this
you will see the relation
with the formulation
um
okay so just to explain here
what's happening with you so the moment
you work with you with this primitive
you get actually a nicer question why
first of all i don't have the aud
anymore i just have a simple one single
pd
here i solve a hit equation you see with
a bounded right hand side
this is l infinity for free because it's
the characteristic of a set so it's one
inside the set zero outside
so the set here is u positive
and here the key fact is the following
um
i will not check it for you but here the
the so because ice is melting in my
phenomenon
if
so the marquia that you have to make
is that if
tx
is
in the ice
which means theta equals zero
then also
sx is in the ice
for every
s
less than t
so the ice is melting so if at some
point you're still ice it means your ice
in the past because once you melt you
cannot get ice you cannot become ice
anymore
um
so this this property implies
very easy from this formula that the set
u equals zero is the same as the set
theta equals zero
so although you have done a change of
variable which has changed the function
changes regularities and many things
that are not obvious relation i mean
if you give me u you can compute theta
but you know the relation between u and
p that's not so easy to express because
i don't know if i tell you that some
regularity probabilities of u are
difficult to implement of theta
especially the space one
so even if i did the change of variable
the key point is that i didn't change
the free boundary so u equals zero is
the set i want to understand
uh and now you solve the integration
with the right hand side and infinity
and then by parabolic regularity implies
that u is c1 in space
and so u you see is a non-negative
function which is c1 in space and so if
you're a non-negative
function at the set where u is zero
which is the minimum the gradient will
be zero
so here at the free boundary now the
gradient of u is zero so while with
theta you see theta was forming an angle
here
here there was an angle in the graph of
theta
you
won't do that so you will look something
like this
now if this is ice
and and then the equation that you solve
is
well where u is positive the
characteristic is minus one so you have
this heat equation with right hand side
minus one we use positive
and where u is zero u is zero so nothing
to say
okay
so this is the problem we want to
understand the regularity of you and the
relatively boundary usually they go
together
so for natural questions what can i say
about you and what you can say about the
free boundary
so
the answer to question one was given in
the 16th and 70s
is a classical result that u is c1 in
time and c11 is place
so this means that u is differentiable
and dtu is a continuous function
and then u is twice differentiable in
space
but the action is only bounded it's not
continuous
and this regularities is optimal because
you see that dtu
minus laplacian of u is minus the
characteristic of u positive
which is not continuous because it's a
characteristic function so it jumps
but you know that this is continuous
i told you
which means that this guy the laplacian
is not continuous
but the laplacian is nothing but the
trace of dash
so it's the sum of the pure second
derivatives
so in space
so if the laplacian is not continuous in
particular the action cannot be
continuous so the mess you can opt for
is boundedness and that's what we know
uh what about the right of the interface
well there are the interface
there is kind of
bootstrap type regularity results that
tells you that if the free boundary is
kind of c1 then it's infinity
what do i mean by c1
what i mean by c1 it means that i have a
region let's say a small ball
and i have an
upper surface sigma which is of class c1
and then
here is ice
and
here well this is not a good color here
here is water okay so when i say
mountain feedback one is like it's a c1
upper surface which nicely separates
on one side
from i from the other side if you are in
this setting
and if the surface is c1 then it in fact
is infinity
actually even analytic
so you have kind of a
regular theory but then the question is
okay but how often can i say that my
surface my free boundary is c1 how often
can i apply this theorem
this was cafarelli breakthrough in 77
which proved that up to some singular
points the free boundary c1 so let me
explain this now
so the way the gratitude of cafarelli
goes is by what's called the blob
technique
so what cafferelli did is the following
it took a free boundary point so a point
on the interface
and it started to rescale the solution
to a change of variable okay so it just
rescaled the function u
by zooming in so taking new variables in
such a way
that you kind of look closer and closer
to the free boundary point and then it
took limit points of this so it was like
a way to look at the infinitesimal
behavior of the solution around the free
boundary point
why this scaling why you have an r
square here an r here and an r squared
there because you can check that dtur
minus laplacian of ur is still equal to
minus characteristic of you are positive
so this is the scale that preserves
the pd
and then you just look at the possible
limited limiting scenarios
okay
first possibility
suppose that the free boundary is super
nice you see on the left i have ice on
the right i have water
then my you should look something like
this so assume already everybody is nice
i know that you look like that
i zoom in and zoom in and zoom in
you see that this
surface this upper surface here it must
if it was smooth if it were smooth
as i zoom in and there is scale it will
become flatter and flatter and then in
the limit the upper surface will become
a hyperplane
and then in the limit i have a solution
which is global
and the zero level set so the free
boundary is a hyperplane so expect it to
be just a one dimensional solution
something like this so if you look at
one dimensional solution to the stefan
problem
uh
you will see that they have to be
obtained by blow up you will see that
they have to be stationary
and the only possibility actually is
that they are like zero on the light and
a parabola
zero on the left and the parabola on the
right
so these are the only possible blow ups
if you have a super nice configuration
this is not super difficult to check so
if you're a nice configuration
then this is what you expect to see
but this is a posteriori right so if i'm
nice i'm gonna see this
and then i use this as a definition of
what it's gonna be for me a regular
point
what could happen also it could happen
that the ice is super thin so you see
the zero read the general value zero
which is here
this is again the ice is super thin so u
is positive almost everywhere just
outside of a small region and as you
rescale and blow up you will get
something like a for example quadratic
polynomial
this is a solution to stefan problem is
a stationary solution
uh with where the isis just
lives on a lower dimensional set of
measures zero so the from an analytic
point of view there is no ice because
the ice now is measured zero
and this is what we call singular point
we see why essentially these are the
points where topology change
something bad happens on the eyes and
it's difficult to understand evolution
so we call singular point every time we
blow up you get something of this form
and in general you can get any quadratic
polynomial so one half a x x
a this matrix should be non-negative
this is because u is not negative so the
block of v will be non-negative and
trace of a equal 1 is to guarantee that
p2 of x
laplacian of p2 of x is equal to the
characteristic of v2 positive
which is almost everywhere we want
um
okay so these are the two definitions
that catherine gave uh just to give give
you a sense of what could happen you
think for instance in 3d
the eyes could have different behaviors
for instance you could think of a block
of ice
like here on the left this block so this
is made like of a thin layer of lies ice
which where there are two blocks so the
block is very thin around the
around the plane
this plane would be like x2 equals zero
so the ice is very thin but it looks
like kind of two-dimensional around this
singular point x0
so this is what the kind of picture you
expect to see if you had two fronts of
ice which are like two parallel plates
that start to melt and melt until they
touch
and here they are touching along the
line
or
i could have a situation like this where
the ice was looking like more of a
thermal or a cylindrical type shape the
ice melts and at some moment
the the cylinder will the neck of the
cylinder will shrink to a point and i
will get a picture of more of this form
so these are just two possible scenarios
they're actually extremely different for
a simple reason
in this picture in the left picture
you see that if you have this label eyes
and the slide device looks like two
planes
what happens to the right of one plane
and to the left
it's kind of independent because the
because a plane separates our tree
the water on one side doesn't see the
water on the other side
so this makes a huge difference at the
pv level instead if your block of ice is
more like a cylinder the water sees
everything right the cylinder doesn't
disconnect
r3 and so this is really affected at the
analytic level
okay these are just possible examples
and the breakthrough of cafe was to show
that this is the only thing that can
happen in the sense that
if you give me a free boundary point
either is regular
and in that case if it's regular it's
going to be analytic in a neighborhood
the free boundary or it's singular in
which case my eyes is extremely thin
so
what happens is that
if you look inside the bowl of reducer
your eyes lives
nearby a little over neighborhood what
plane of a hydroplane
okay
um
so in cafe 77 to be honest the second
statement was not proved so so precisely
uh you need to you to add some arguments
which have which that cafe approved in
98
but
let's say
the code was there in 77.
um
okay so this is the situation so the
real the free boundary regular part of
the fund is analytic and then we have
the singular part
what can we say about this singular part
this is our question
so this you have these three boundaries
are set in space time right because as
time evolves the free boundary change so
it's really a set which lives in space
time so let me set some notation
so i will look so this i will look at
sigma the singular points of the free
boundary and i can
let's say uh look at them as a union of
slice of singular points for each team
so
for each t i look at the singular points
of my free boundary and then i do the
unit over t and this will be my singular
set
okay so this is the decomposition
and and then you ask yourself what can i
say about the regularity
of the slice
answer
the sigma t is contained in a c one m
minus one dimensional method
okay let me comment on this this is
important let me give you an example
here so i zoom in a second
and let me show you an example so let's
say we are in n equal to
and let's say that the ice looks like
this
it's like a drop this is all eyes
then you have a tiny one-dimensional
line of eyes so this is again equal zero
and this again
okay so this is u equals zero
in this so this comes so one millisecond
before your eyes was probably thicker
like this right it was probably
something like this
and then it melted and then you got a
line
okay let's remove now these points and
let's go back to our picture which is
which can happen we know you can build
examples having this
now the question is what are the
singular regular points in this picture
the regular points are this part of the
free boundary
is the region where you have eyes on one
side
and water on the other so this is
regular
and this is regular
instead
this line
is singular
okay
this is sigma t for some time
okay now you see that the free boundary
the regular part is n minus one
dimensional it's a curve in dart tool
and the singular set is also m minus one
dimensional is a curve is a segment
inner two
so the singular set is as large as the
regular set okay
not very good right i mean
a lot of similar points
and also if you look at them in space
time so you have a nice regularizing
space like c1
but because of the parabolic scaling
time sk and space don't scale the same c
one regulation time will give you only c
one alpha right sorry see whatever y
space gives you only c one alpha
gradient time
which is also rather bad because i mean
if you think that the brownian motion is
uh older continuous with this point one
alpha it would mean that the three bow
the singular set
could look like uh
the the the shape of the single set will
be could be like a square emotion
so so
this all the regularity is not so
appealing
in particular if you ask yourself okay i
have a set which for every t is minus
one dimensional and then you can glue
them uncountably many of them because
then the singular set
is this union over time how large is
this
if i look it in rn plus r
so this set
if you look at in a parabolic scaling
piece as dimension m plus two
because you have to think that time is
paired times space scale differently in
time you scale like r square t and it
space you can rx
so rn is dimension n but our in
parabolic scaling is dimension two okay
so you have a m plus two dimensional set
which is your ambient space and inside
this m plus two dimensional spread which
is the right outsole dimension to use
how large is the singular set
okay
uh the regular set will be n plus one
for dimension one
what about this one
okay
so remember this is optimal n minus one
for each team and then what we so if you
apply the theorem of cafarelli you will
get
uh in company you will get ten plus one
alpha
actually what we prove with throstoton
and zero is that the singular set is
dimension still m minus one
so not all even if each slice at most is
m minus one dimensional when you glue
them together over t you will still get
something n minus one dimensional for
this parabolic dimension
which morally means that the set of
times
where
you see something minus one dimensional
should have dimension zero
because just by numerology so it should
be extremely rare to see something which
is n minus one dimensional otherwise if
it was not real you will see a huge set
as you glue them
so this is optimal for the simple reason
that this is larger than the dimension
of sigma t for something
and this is we say i told you that there
is t for which this is minus one
so you will take the max over t
very well
so this is the optimal bound but
actually we can do much better what we
can say is something like this
that up to a set of even co-dimension
two sorry of dimension m minus two which
is conventional four in space time if
you think that the world space time is
dimension plus two
uh you have
something like an ass infinite expansion
of your u
around
every single point
so this means the following essentially
that around a singular point
you will have a behavior which looks
something like this let me do the
picture in one plus one dimension which
is completely cheating because of course
you cannot do this in higher dimension
but let's say if i was in in one
dimension x and t
this would be the ice
and then i'm telling you that here in
this part use infinity
in this part u is infinity
and so in each of the two sides use
infinity and i have a precise expansion
so this part of the expansion is telling
me what you is here and this part of the
expansion is telling me how ubis on the
left
uh this proving this theory in one
dimension is easy because
in one dimension left a segment always
disconnects and so as i told you what
happens to the right will not see what
happens to the left and so sometimes you
have just a nice evolution on the right
that doesn't see the front coming so
here you see there are these two fronts
that are going to meet at the origin of
ice but until they meet they don't know
that they don't know that they exist
each each of them doesn't know that the
other one exists
and what we are tell saying
is that up to a co-dimensional
um fourth set in our end in our space
time
this is what you see all the time
so in fact the behavior is the same
which means that really you always most
of the time you see really these two
fronts meeting
in every dimension
of course you they will not see you
cannot expect them to really separate
there is not really separation but
almost let's say the separation is good
enough so that you can still prove this
here
what about the the remaining parts of
this
the remaining parts of this for instance
are the one that i described before so
there will be these points
where the eyes
force my neck right so like these
cylindrical shapes okay around this
point the theorem will not apply
and the question is how what can i say
about you
so if you look at caferelli the he told
the cafe theorem about singular points
me
tells you that you have an expansion of
this form this is just uh caferelli
77 the one i said before
another this is so saying that you are
converge
to a polynomial
p2 where p2 is of this form is the same
as saying that you have a taylor
expansion of these four
and then what we prove
is that every time you are in a
situation
where this p2 so this polynomial has
so let's say the matrix a here
this matrix a
let me choose a different color this
matrix a as rank greater equal than two
which is for instance in this case where
the the ice
becomes a segment
then the solution is is this expansion
of fairly sharp
you cannot put any higher not even an
epsilon power there you can prove you
can put okay so it's like there is this
strong dichotomy where you have
expansion synthesis functions at some
point and points where the expansion
stops almost immediately like c2 is
phase c1 in time no more
but this is still good because it allows
us anyhow to get a very good
understanding of these singular points
and then we started to understand out of
this how the singular set is really
behaving in space-time
so to understand the the free boundary
you need to understand the solution
first
because then you get a lot of
informations you see once you know what
is you you know what is its zero set
and the corollary of all these theorems
are the following
first corollary
the sigma infinity part which is most of
the boundary is covered by c infinity
manifolds so not manifold as i told you
c one is space c zero one alpha in time
no it's infinite in space time
so most of the free boundary is actually
covered by symphony manifolds of the
singular part of the keyboard
and then if you look how often in time
you will see points in sigma infinity
this has dimension zero so these points
are extremely light in time they are
very large in space
but you see them very early in time
what about the point sigma prime so
these are the points corresponding to
chords
sorry two cylinders these points
the how often will i see a cylinder in
time so how often time my free boundary
which will look my eyes will look like a
cylinder
the the dimension is minus over two
and then for almost every t the single
set is convention
for
uh in a random
so this says that okay it's true that
the free boundary is n minus
one-dimensional for each t
it's true that the singular set could be
n minus one-dimensional but almost every
time actually then one is
so it's much much smaller so if you take
a random time you will never see a big
single ascent
and in particular this is relevant if
you are in the physical dimension three
but also dimension two is interesting
that it tells you that the set of times
where you see c where you see singular
points so the set of times where your
the ice doesn't look analytic
as dimension and minus over 2
which means that if you are in dimension
2
this is zero and if you're in dimension
three
this is one alpha
so anyhow measure zero but much better
there's a very low of the dimension
so this is to say in reality there are
singular points
but they're rare
and we can actually say a lot of how
often you see large single set of things
is more single set and so on
uh two signal points exist of course
exist
and this is like this picture right
where you see
this neck
right the ice is melting there and uh
eventually this will break you will have
a a single point of singular point and
then you will have a change in topology
where the ice breaks into parts so
clearly singular points exist
and uh that's all i wanted to say and i
thank you for your attention
uh thank you alexa that's a tremendous
result
any questions or comments
thank you alessio
so i wanted to ask how
how general you think of a result
disease
and
so what you will need to apply to other
kind of equation like
just i don't know putting some drifts or
uh
you know some lower order reaction term
or something like that so do you need do
you expect that this is a
rather general in general technique or
you need some peculiar stuff to do it
yeah so thanks for the question uh no so
no i would say so there are two
the techniques are the following so um
let me go to the pda perhaps
so
let's put it this way here you have a
characteristic of a set which is your
singular point
let's say your your enemy because it's a
singular right-hand side
so um
essentially the first question is how
large is this guy
so i feel at a singular point singular
point is where the eyes is thin
which means the right hand side is
actually small
so if you
go through this philosophy
this
argument allows you to say a lot about
the solution you
let's say and you can prove an expansion
so
i told you that you have an expansion up
to this infinity order
essentially a lot around a lot of points
thanks to this fact that the size is
small
plus okay other techniques
uh you can prove like an expansion up to
order three so you you know cafarelli
gives you a c a sort of c2 expansion you
can push it to c3 because the the at
singular point there is a small
then once you are at c3 essentially the
key properties like
is that this then it becomes critical so
if you're at the c3 scaling so if you
try to above
this characteristic
right hand side is as large
essentially as the
what you're trying to do i mean once you
scale cubically this is going to be a
huge right hand side
and that's where the new techniques come
in and they're very robust i mean
they're really based on the fact
that uh there's two fronts it always hit
with zero with
positive speed so these are barrier
arguments
and and then the most delicate part is
to prove that if you are c3 then you can
become c3 plus
epsilon the moment you break c3 and you
are ct plus epsilon then you go to
infinity in a much more straightforward
way so there is the core of the paper is
to break that
uh so
if you give me like lower order terms
drift uh or anything so as long as the
what you give me
i will say it doesn't matter uh it's uh
so that because then it would be like
eight equation with lower other terms
which are still not so i mean
what what creates a singularity is that
is the ice it's this characteristic
functions are not the lower of the terms
so
maybe so i didn't try but that's my
quick answer i think it's very robust as
an approach
more questions
yeah i just wanted to ask you so uh with
drift though um i mean i i agree with
you that once uh the transformation is
successful
one can treat it as a lower order term
however this
integration right i mean it uses the
monotonicity
so it drift things will uh i you know so
so that was my um
yeah so um i i agree so i cheated on
that right so but uh there is a dif
there is i the only thing i notice so i
you know before doing the parabolic
observer problem we did a lot on the
elliptic obstacle like issue
okay
and there if you want to go to higher
order expansion like you want to go uh
c2 c3c force infinity expansion for your
solution
um which is like so you don't have the
bpu
then you need monotonicity formulas to
every order so you need you apply kind
of algorithm type of z formula and uh
so multi-format to get to c3 then to c3
plus something then to c4 c5 and so on
it's solved by multiforme
here in
stefan the monday formula are good up to
order three
so i haven't checked if the drifts
really mess up up toward the three but
let's say the moment you get a c
three
a cubic expansion of u
then
you just need to break
the the three order to get to infinity
because the once you have c3 plus alpha
is the moment where you start to say
that morally
what you have two fronts of eyes and
what happens to the right and what
happens to the left doesn't ma the
doesn't see each other so this is the
principle
so we don't use i mean controversy
formula to go from c3 to infinity
so that's why i think sometimes this
kind of problem is more robust
than foreign version of it
now i i agree with you i haven't checked
the drift at which moment it breaks
uh the kind of monetary formula like in
algorithm but
all i'm saying is that if i can i could
get to c3 then i would go on so i think
it's
more robust
and in particular if you do reaction
diffusion so if there is not even a
drift like what
was asked right then i wouldn't see a
problem there
but
i haven't checked
anymore
thank you very much for the very nice
job i have two questions so the first
one is about like whenever you have a
inequality uh in dimension
uh do you believe the the the the
this the bound would be optimal or is
there any way to show the lower pound as
well
and the second question is um like when
uh so this in this singular points where
you like have this
matrix a with a rank two so the set of
matrices that you have like are those
like a dense set like in the space of
like the
set of matrices of rank 2 or like just
like a few
matrices with rank 2.
okay so
second question i can ask real quickly
you can get any so any of for any
metrics
even on rank not two this is a the one
alpha axx is a stationary solution of
stefan
so
i would expect you can construct any
metrics of rank two there is no special
structure here so
there is no reason for respect that
there are some values which are not
attainable here as blood possible blocks
so i would say all of them are possible
about the bounds of the dimension so the
m is one dimensional bound is optimal
here
the
sigma infinity here is
optimal
this oops sorry
this
one is optimal of course
uh
the
this bound
i
if you ask me i would believe it's
optimal
more because in the lifty case i can
build the solution so this is based on a
kind of sub-type theorem
uh which is really how the points
behaves so if we look it
at this bound
i don't know it looks rather optimal but
from the method we employ and the
analysis i don't have a proof of that
for sure the minus 2 over 2 that we get
here
here
this comes
both from this analysis and but also
from another set of points that they
didn't talk about
and so this second one the the one at
the bottom is even more likely that it's
true so n equals zero so if n equal two
we get zero which means that the set of
which is almost optimal probably the
optimal one would be that the dimension
to the single set is countable perhaps
and so i can build examples with
countable sets and here i'm proving
dimension zero so it's almost there
for one for dimension 3 and this one
alpha
if i had to bet i would bet it's optimal
again because of this criticality in all
these constructions
but of course i have no proof there i
have no no idea how to build an example
of solution to staff and that as a
singular set which is so large
so that's a big open problem
and it will be extremely interesting to
see if that's sharp
so my bet will be yes
but more because
from the analysis we do we see how
critical it is in many steps i don't
have like more than that there's a
reason so perhaps i'm biased as well but
that's my
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you